hello this is a comprehensive paper
review on the paper called memory
assisted prompt editing to improve gpt3
after deployment as the title says this
paper is really cool because it is able
to improve these large language models
after they're deployed so this video
right here is a comprehensive review on
the paper after you've watched the video
you'll have a good idea of what the
method does what it is and what the
paper describes the next video released
tomorrow will be an interview with the
authors of the paper and that is also
really cool and i definitely learned a
lot from that as well so i invite you to
check out both and i'll see you around
have fun hey there today's sponsor is
the course on introduction to graph
neural networks this is a course by my
friend zach jost who is an expert in
graph neural networks he's packed all
his knowledge into one course that will
educate you on both the theoretical and
hands-on practical aspect on graph
neural networks graph neural networks
are really important they're definitely
one of the most interesting areas in
deep learning right now they've also
powered a lot of recent advances in
scientific breakthroughs such as alpha
fault protein structure predictions or
better traffic predictions if you use my
link you'll get a 15 discount on the
course enrollment is open right now and
lasts until april 1st or until spaces
run out alright let's get into the video
now see ya
hello there today we're looking at
memory assisted prompt editing to
improve gpt3 after deployment by aman
madan niko tandon and others so this
paper proposes a method to improve gpt 3
in an interactive mode in a user
feedback mode here is a little sample of
how that could look like so the user
would pose a question to gpt3 for
example what word is similar to good
and this is not displayed here but
in
advance of that there would be like an
entire prompt like you would be used to
for prompting gpt3 if you don't know
about gpt3 i've made a video on gpt3 uh
extensively describing how that works
and how to construct these prompts right
here
so that gpt3 gives you what you want
supposedly because it doesn't always
work for example here the user asks what
word is similar to good and gpt3 says
the homonym of good is wood which is
kinda true
but the user doesn't is not specified
clearly what similar means the user here
had a different intent which then the
user specifies user says similar to
means with a similar meaning
so the user didn't mean a word that
sounded like good which is would the
word the user meant a word that is kind
of like a synonym instead of a homonym
so
in this new system
this thing right here would be called
feedback and the user would be able to
give this feedback to gpt-3
and then gpt3 would write that to memory
it's not actually gpt3 it's sort of like
a plugin that the paper develops
and then the user
the next time the user asks for example
what word is similar to surprised
the system will remember that the last
time the user asked the question like
that like similar to you know what word
is similar to another word
the system will go back to the memory
retrieve the feedback right here
put it into the prompt and then guides
gpt3 to actually to actually
answer in the correct way and so gpth3
here says the synonym of surprised is
amazed
so multiple things to see right here
first of all
their plugin the system that the paper
here proposes can be added to any
pre-trained language model and the
language model itself doesn't have to be
changed which is really important for
something like gpt3 because that's too
big to to change i guess you can fine
tune it but uh you'd need a lot more
data than just two or three examples
the other thing is that it is
interactive so this is an interactive
user session where the user can specify
not only clarifications for things that
are clearly wrong but also maybe
personal preferences so this is
goes beyond what this paper shows and
this paper is mostly about
either factual accuracy like accuracy of
the task or
figuring out user intent from ambiguous
meanings this could easily be used to
personalize interaction with gpt-3 for
particular users by interactively
letting them improve the system this is
kind of like what you know normies think
of ais like a system that learns from
the two or three times that i give it
feedback and then gets better over time
so this is pretty cool
um and lastly what was i gonna say um i
don't i don't remember anymore
but we're going to look at how this
works and you know what's good about it
what's bad about it
and yeah that's that's about it
so
here is the proposed before and after of
the system if the user with no memory
asks gpd3 the user gives an x
um
as we said it's it's always prefixed
with some sort of a prompt that
guides gpt3 into giving the correct
answer structure or type of answer if
we're going to look at some of these
prompts in just a second
and gpt3 will give some sort of an
answer now this might be good or bad as
you may have seen it can turn out not
the in the best way
so in their memory enhanced gpt3 example
the user would give a
question x now let's disregard the
memory for now let's just go directly to
gpt3 which is what happens in the very
first iteration of this interaction so
gpt-3 now has a prompt in front of it as
well but a prompt that the authors here
designed such that gpd3 doesn't only
give the answer to the question but also
you the understanding of what the user
meant so
up here you can see that
by gpth3 answers the homonym of good is
wood right gpd3 doesn't just answer
would which would be the answer but also
this first part right here which is this
understanding
so the authors construct this sort of
meta prompt that they give and that
instructs gpt3 not only to to give the
answer but also to give the
understanding like a clear
a clear output of what it understood the
user can then take
that
and decide if that's what the user
wanted or not
so if the user is happy then all is good
if the user is not happy the user can
give feedback to gpt3 the user gives
feedback in kind of in natural language
just like types it up like no i didn't
mean this i meant this other thing
and
you have to type it up in a bit of a
special way you have to type it up you
can't just say no
i guess you can but it's best if you
write like
similar to means with a similar meaning
so you clarify your original question
right here um
and by doing that you committed to the
memory
now obviously
what you could do is you could simply
add that clarification to the prompt go
back to gpthree and actually let it
answer correctly which would work but
we're not only about this prompt the
idea here is that this feedback will
help guide gpt 3 in all subsequent
prompts
because the user is likely going to
express themselves in the same way gpt3
if it misunderstood is likely going to
misunderstand in the same way so this
memory serves as a bit of a
generalizable correction mechanism that
learns from few items of feedback
so let's let's look what happens the
second time around so the second time
the user again has a question x we then
go first to the memory and we see
or x prime let's call that x prime we
see is there anything in the memory that
is similar to x prime meaning that is
there any question before that has been
submitted to gpd3 in the current session
it doesn't need to be in the same prompt
or anything just in the current user
session
um
that has been misunderstood
so do we have an instance that is close
to x prime
where feedback was given that would be
part of the memory and this is being
done with either semantic similarities
or the so you take some sort of a
of a
language model or some sort of a
sequence model for example a transformer
you look at the embeddings of the
sentences you compare them via cosine
similarity you can also do word overlap
or something like this but what you want
to do is you want to retrieve those
instances of feedback
and then you want to add that feedback
to the prompt
in the very case in the case that you
so this is hidden here
this is hidden it just says and adds to
prompt and we're going to see how this
happens how the system adds that to the
prompt
it's actually quite simple it's mainly a
concatenation
adds it to the prompt so the users this
is the x prime right here the x prime
is being augmented with the feedback
that the user has given previously
and then submitted to gpt3 and
with that feedback gpt3 is now able to
actually
more likely give the correct answer and
if you know if it's misunderstood the
user can give feedback again
and that would make it even better in
the next few iterations
so this is the overarching system the
paper makes pretty clear that it doesn't
propose like
it doesn't purport to be
the state of the art or the final the
final system in this
framework it simply wants to present a
framework
uh that's it states that i think two
times or or more now uh
there i have mixed opinions on papers
that say well we just want to present a
framework on the one hand it's obviously
good to present a framework uh your
paper like papers shouldn't be rejected
if they have a good idea for a new
framework just because they can't get it
to you know be super duper performant
um on the other hand saying you know we
just want to propose a framework
is very often it's either like a cop out
for not reaching good numbers or or just
kind of like
you know we
we we want to split one paper into two
papers because the next paper is going
to be sort of the the well-performing
thing or
it just there's a danger that it's not
super well thought through because the
authors haven't actually put in like
massive efforts into making this good at
which point uh many flaws reveal
themselves in these types of frameworks
but the framework's pretty general so
you know we'll we'll give them we'll
give them that
they claim yeah so this is
what i just explained they maintain a
memory m
of feedback as a set of key value pairs
the key is a misunderstood question and
the value is the user's feedback to
correct that misunderstanding
given a new question we check if the
model has made a mistake on a similar
question earlier
by querying the memory for a similar
question a found append the
corresponding feedback to the question
prompt
and yeah here is where they say
not definitive rather our main
contribution is the general framework
itself suggesting how user feedback
might continuously improve model
performance without retraining in a few
shot prompt settings
so let's look in in a little bit more
detail into the system the system has
four distinct parts this memory that
we've just talked about that's a growing
table of key value pairs the key being
questions that have been misunderstood
and the value being user feedback
so obviously the user only chooses to
give feedback if the user was
misunderstood and therefore the memory
only contains those things
there's a lookup function which i guess
is the most complicated or more most
complex or complicated which one uh i'm
i'm too surajd
um the most complicated
of the functions right here it's they
call it a learned retriever that matches
the query against all the keys of m so
that's where we retrieve
similar prompts that have
been misunderstood in the past and as i
said we can do that with a pre-trained
embedding for example of a transformer
model or any any sort of embedding model
for text
or any other thing they use levenshtein
distance for some experiments so
the combiner
is a
gating function allowing irrelevant
retrieved feedback to be ignored i don't
i don't think they actually do
i don't think they do that right now to
ignore irrelevant feedback
other than thresholding the lookup
function so the lookup function is an
inner product and i guess the combiner
is the threshold on that inner product
the prompter
here it passes the output of the
combiner to the prompt and
so that in our case this is just going
to be a concatenation of the prompt and
whatever the combiner outputs
so
it's going to be the prompt plus the
question if there was nothing found in
the memory or the prompt plus the
question plus the feedback if it was
found in memory
so
i would
yeah let's let's get into the task and
then we'll get into the actual examples
so they have two kinds of tasks the
first kind of tasks there are five tasks
that are broadly in the category of word
scrambling and manipulation for example
to reorder some letters these are
re-ordered in exact reverse uh
other there are other they're anagram
one anagram two and so on
there are very
various tasks five of these and there
are five lexical qa tasks which are
asking gpt3 for a synonym for an antonym
for a homonym and so on
they say for each task
the prompt contains a few different
variations
for example
what is the homonym of a word
what sounds like the word uh they create
a data set so
this is
where
yeah we'll get to that as well they
create a data set
of
samples feedback understanding and the
solution so essentially without the
feedback this would be what you would
give to gpt3 as a prompt they also
collect feedback so they can simulate
users
so they
they
they give the x to gpt3 and if it is
misunderstood and they do that in a they
determine that in a heuristic way they
also provide the feedback to the memory
so they come up with
sort of invented data of users being
understood or misunderstood
the
yeah the retriever as i already said is
either a semantic similarity using the
cosine distance with a threshold or a
lexical similarity and heuristics for
similarity matching
the combiner concatenates x and the
feedback received by the retriever
and the prompter concatenates the prompt
and whatever the combiner outputs
we didn't have one of them no
oh no the combiner is the gating
function
okay
that doesn't it doesn't seem like much
of a gating function
um yeah so i want to jump over the
results quite quickly to show you some
examples of how that even might look
like
so
here is a prompt
for
the tasks i think these are the lexical
the lexical keyway tasks so asking for
antonyms and homonyms this is the entire
thing that you would give to gpt3 in
front of your question so you would
append your question down here somewhere
like below the prompt in the same style
as the prompt so this is
this is uh
this is how you query gpt3 what you
would do is you would complete simply
give some examples
and
prime gpt3 to continue the pattern
so they hear they ask what is the
homonym for ring
the homonym for ring is ring
now these are all human generated right
all of these are human generated so you
prime gpt3 to you know what how how
questions are asked
and how answers are given
the important thing right here to see is
that all of the answer patterns they
provide
is it's not just the um
the answer for example
permit is the antonym for prohibition
the
answer also contains this understanding
part this thing right here the antonym
for prohibition is that's the
understanding and this right here
is the label
this is important because the
understanding is what the user uses to
decide whether or not gpt3 has
understood the question
what they also do later in the same
prompt they as you can see
they also add
um
questions with feedback so here you see
how they incorporate the feedback
there's like this i don't know what
that's called a pipe symbol
and then it says clarification colon and
then this here is the feedback okay so
this is also part of the prompt so the
prompt contains some generic
feedback where
there is some sort of an unclear or
ambiguous question then there is
feedback and then there is the correct
answer that is based on the feedback
so
um you can see right here the question
is and that's pretty special the
question is
or up here it says
what is the synonym for right and then
the answer is the synonym for is
so it always goes after the question how
the question is formulated the
understanding goes after the question
however they prime gpt3 that if there is
a clarification you can see
that
the answer
goes
sometimes partially sometimes fully on
the clarification what what i mean by
goes on i mean
it
it refers to so the understanding
reflects the clarification
that allows multiple things it allows if
the user is still not understood it uh
allows the user to give feedback again
and also it primes gpt3 to actually pay
attention to this clarification part
so in the prompt you'll get a bunch of
these clarifications
to teach gpt3 how to include these
clarifications
in its output this
is pretty smart it so the prompt is not
only a prompt for
uh what kind of answers you want the
prompt is also a prompt for this
understanding part which is a necessary
precondition of making the
uh of making the system interactive
and
the prompt also
includes the next step of the
interactivity and how to react to it
this is i think this is a it's a good
piece of prompt engineering
people are getting better at this by the
day
so this is this is before
the question even gets here so the
question would be added here
um and if there is feedback in the
memory the feedback would obviously be a
pendant with a pipe symbol and
clarification
and then the feedback would be added
here and then gpt3 would be prompted to
give its answer right here you can see
if there is something in the memory
gpt3 already knows how to use these
clarification parts right here
so it's pretty good
um
yeah that's there there are a bunch of
examples uh you can we can we can maybe
look at them or you can look at them
what
i want to look at lastly is the data set
generation so
they simply
say that they created a data set
we manually created 15 task templates
with three variants of phrasing the
question for each task you know this is
this is fine this is prompt engineering
um
they also
they also do
come up with sort of the variations for
the feedback
where have i
data sets templates phrasing each
question
okay
i cannot
i can't come up with but it is my
understanding
that they create the entire data set so
they create the prompts and then the
tasks they get from other papers for
example
the synonyms the homonyms and so on they
get from other data sets that other
papers have as well
but then the feedback
the feedback they also
do themselves and there is a danger
right here because they create
the
task samples for prompting right
and also us here they
they create
they create the prompts they create the
task samples for the prompts they also
create the example feedbacks and they
create the data set of feedbacks which
is dangerous because
that might lead to you know me just kind
of formulating these tasks at templates
not as accurately as you know maybe
i could
and then obviously once i clarify i get
an improvement
so the data set creation here if i
understand it correctly being manual
is a big
interference i guess just from a
research standpoint
with
the researchers interest like there's a
conflict of interest in making this data
set and what you want to get out of the
data set
so that is just one concern that i would
have right here the other concern
as you can see
is
if you're
if your retrieved clarification from the
memory so this thing here comes from the
memory
if that is wrong like if it's actually
not related to the question right here
then things could go bad because gpt3
given the prompt is explicitly trained
to address whatever is in the
clarification in its answer and that
could be
not
not super duper
um relevant it could actually be
destructive
so gpd3 could be completely correct in
answering the question yet if the
clarification is wrong it could output a
wrong answer
and that's that's not entirely
you know that's not entirely
good
or maybe
maybe i've misunderstood
something because what i can also
imagine is that
the
memory contents
are
somehow appended
to the prompt itself so the question
and the clarification
which
and that's what i don't know and that's
what i would like to to ask the authors
because it's not entirely clear to me uh
what they do
they compare two different baselines
right here and it could also be that
the baselines implement some of what i
just said so for example
let's go here
the no mem that's just gpt3 then there
is the grow prompt and grow prompt
says the prompt is continuously grown
with a subset of memory
m that can fit within the prompt so i
think
this grow prompt thing right here
that's where i have my prompt that we've
just seen and then i would just add like
all the entries of m or as many as i
could
here and then i would add x so there
would be no clarification over here for
x never in this grow prompt it would
just be that this
portion of memory here
grows and there would always be an x and
a clarification or a feedback fb and
then x and an fb so and all the things
that i've gotten wrong in the past
would be appended here as pairs of
sample and
feedback
and then this is compared to
this memprompt system that's the system
that they have
now again it is not clear to me because
tech like is not clear to me if their
system simply retrieves the most
relevant unit here and appends it here
instead of the m
so or maybe the
all the relevant units right
um
in which case there would also be no
feedback here or if their system
retrieves the most relevant thing and
then appends only the feedback
to the x right here
i don't know
like i don't know
it concatenates c at the end of p
and c
concatenates x and the feedback
retrieved
so i'm pretty i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that it's the second one
it depends it concatenates the feedback
to x
however here it says they use a cosine
distance with a threshold of 0.9 there
is no mention of like a maximum
like they retrieve
the maximal feedback it seems like this
could result in an entire set of
feedbacks
um
yeah but i don't want to go too deep
into that i think i've understood
correctly the danger here is that
the green stuff like the grow prompt the
way i understand it is not like a
perfect baseline for what they do
because the grow prompt inserts the
memory samples as such with the original
questions and their system only inserts
the
it only inserts the
feedback after the question that's
currently happening so
either we need a baseline that also adds
only feedback right here but selected in
a maybe less smart way
or we need as a baseline a system that
selects the feedback in a smart way but
then
then tries to
prepend the original question with that
feedback in front of x and leave x
without feedback or without
clarification
so i think you know just baseline wise
that is what would be needed
but you can see in their experiments uh
they show
i guess convincingly that they are able
to improve the accuracy these here are
steps these are not training steps these
are steps of interaction with the system
so the system is never trained it's
simply interacted with and this memory
is filled up you can see uh
interestingly at the beginning
everything fails
um
which which is interesting right because
one would expect that at least this
memprompt system would remain the same i
guess gpt3 remains the same but but the
memprompt system also declines now if
the retriever
is
pre-trained and fixed
and the threshold is selected well
it should not retrieve any question any
clarifications that have nothing to do
with the questions so the performance in
my mind shouldn't sink this dramatically
which tells me that
the the max function is just very
important so
um they they probably mostly get the
most relevant feedback
um
if it has if it passes the threshold and
here is what happens
i could guess if that feedback is
irrelevant
um so the it would actually bias the
language model towards giving the wrong
answer and only after a while do i have
enough feedback collected that i sort of
accurately cover what i would like to
ask
um yeah you you can see how this this
gets i guess problematic
as soon as your domain of requests to
gpt 3
increases
because uh
there's probably probably doesn't need
to be a huge domain before you start to
over correct
for things but then you might also just
tighten your threshold so you know what
do i know
um however
you know disregarding correcting things
personalization i think might be
just a really neat application of this
uh to just sort of nudge
nudge gpt3 into
a personalized interaction with the user
and if it misunderstands there then it's
i i would guess it's more mild
um than
here where it would just kind of like
it essentially negates an output
essentially says no that's wrong
what's also interesting is that the grow
prompt never reaches
the potential again we don't know if
that is because it's a different
structured prompt
but at least it's partially due to the
fact that it's not smartly selected it
simply appends to whatever is last in
the last few things in the memory
also interestingly this
mem prompt where the probability of
giving feedback is 0.5
it is kind of bad at the beginning so
here the probability of getting feedback
from the memory is only half so half the
time
the memory would have something
but you're not you're not getting it
this is kind of like an artificial
limitation on the system just your
retriever might be bad not recognize
that there's something there
interestingly this also grows to the
same performance and i wonder
why wouldn't i expect this to be you
know only half the gains
because it only in half the time
it actually
gets any clarification so half the time
gpt3 would still output the wrong answer
um i might confuse i might confuse
something here but it seems
to me that that's what should happen
they shouldn't end up at like almost the
same performance
so
that is
the overview largely over the results
they have these other tasks as well
they're much kind of less clear
they say well there's not too many ways
to misunderstand in please turn a word
around or so
they also do
experiments in low resource languages
which is also cool turns out about the
same as you can see right here
so
in conclusion i think this is a neat
idea
i i like
that
it is essentially a suggestion on how to
personalize these language models or how
to adjust them how to make them learn
from very very few things that are
nonetheless bigger than the prompt right
so if you
want to teach gpt3 a new trick and it
sort of exceeds the prompt size
um this might be a very good way to go
if you don't want to go ahead and
fine-tune it which would require much
much more data
what i don't really like about this
paper is the fact that they say oh we
just present the framework it has its
good things but also
um
it's it's bad things they do actually
implement something which is to be
commended
um
but
there
i think the sort of comparison with the
baseline is shaky because it's not the
an exact ablation of what they do uh
there would be would be better things
and
their results although are convincing
apart from the fact that i suspect the
data set creation was done by the same
people who run the study and since since
as far as i can understand it everything
except for you know
the actual synonyms of words
everything else was done in a manual
fashion like coming up with prompts
coming up with potential feedback um
that would
warrant some at least some caution
or maybe one would need to look at the
exact data set and as far as i
understand it that is actually available
so we're able to do that all right that
was it for this paper um thanks for for
listening let me know what you think
of this paper uh it seems like a pretty
neat idea
and
i
am excited to see what other people will
expand on it bye
[Music]
you